[Music]
so thank you David as they've mentioned
my areas string theory it's an area
where we try to understand the
fundamental laws of physics what is
everything made of and what are the
forces between particles and what is the
unification of particles and waters what
are all these ideas come together so
there's a framework very mathematical
where many of these ideas seem to fit
beautifully and that's in the context of
replacing objects which are point
particles instead of point particles
being fundamental entities extended
object like strings one dimensional and
even higher dimensional ones like
membranes being the fundamental entities
instead and that turns out to be
important in trying to reconcile
Einstein's theory of general relativity
with quantum mechanics and it has led to
a number of predictions including
predictions that people had had expected
for example Hawking's predictions about
black holes which were hinted at but was
not quite fully realized until string
theory predicted exactly the numbers and
formulas that Hawking was getting in
terms of properties of black holes so
there are many aspects of this theory
which theoretically have been have been
have been checked out this theory
predicts not just one universe but in
fact an infinite number of universes
10500 is an underestimation so of course
the 10th of the popular 10 the 500
number comes when you try to restrict
the specific type of universe four
dimensions maybe and maybe with
properties similar to ours and within
that context there may be this many
people have tried to estimate I'm not
sure I couldn't that numbers may or may
not be by by colleagues who make such an
estimate but at any rate infinite or at
least a huge number of possibilities in
this theory is predicted that's for sure
and we have seen with in string theory
that there are many possible choices
which more or less resembles what we see
in terms of the forces and particles and
things that we expected in our universe
so it's very natural to expect that that
would that would potentially work the
way we think but they actually pinpoint
which which
we live in and to make exact predictions
is very difficult given the multitude of
possibilities so we are not there yet in
terms of predicting exactly which form
we are and the hope is by finding some
general properties about all of them
perhaps we can say some general lessons
from any would-be universe and one of
them of course being ours we would be
able to deduce some facts about our
universe as a result so I think the
point that John is making is that there
are not everything you can get from
string theory the infinity might mislead
us to think well whatever you want goes
just just pick your universe you're fine
well infinity number exactly because not
only 10 to 500 is big in 57 figure why
not you can get anything who cares about
string theory you can have anything you
want and just anything goes not so fast
it turns out for example in our universe
gravity is the weakest force if you have
for example two electrons next to each
other the electric repulsion is far
stronger than their gravitational
attraction well that's a feature of our
universe do all the universes that tend
to 500 or infinity what we are talking
about they all have this property it
turns out yes it turns out those are
those properties like gravity being the
weakest force seems to be the case in
all the cases that we can construct in
the context of solutions to string
theory so we think that's a general
feature what are general features that
all of these have and therefore if we
believe in string theory as I do our
universe should also have those so that
would be the introductions about our
universe coming from string theory even
though we don't we cannot pinpoint which
one of these universe is exactly our
universe so that we very predicted so
the things that look okay like your
gravity may not be there with his force
I would call they belong to a swampland
they don't really exist we could
contemplate them as would be universes
but not a real universe and so
presumably our universe which is real
would not belong to this well really
according to string theory sorry I'm
just mastering that's the pro I'm
talking about I'm talking about people
like myself who believe in in in the
thing that string theory has already
taught us to have connections with
reality correct I don't want to
sidetrack us too much but that sounds
quite like the anthropic principle
and principle which we can I can
probably no no nice talk I just wanted
to not exactly there and principle is
trying to say that we live it we live in
this universe that universe is the way
it is because we live in it roughly
that's not what I that's not automatic
okay at all
so in fact I'm myself on the fence about
and tropics I'm not you're in the
swampland
no no and tropics and tropics I think
may be helpful to the clarify what that
this is you because some people I think
this understand the statement here yeah
an tropics is nothing to do per se with
that asked if string nice give me the
exist how you use it you can use
different ways and some people have
tried to use it one way or the other I
may or may not agree with the uses of
that terminology by some colleagues even
but that's not the case that's not the
statement about the string theory as a
mathematically well-defined formulas and
tells you that there are these
consistent mathematic consistent
solutions now I think I take issue with
the fact that mathematics is not
interesting that mathematics whatever is
gives us great who cares we have our
universe who charismatic movement I
think we have learned amazingly simple
ideas and math and mathematical
consistency leads us a huge distance the
future for example example is Maxwell
Maxwell was looking at this equation
electricity and magnetism it wasn't
working out because math wasn't working
out he just added the terminus equations
out of just mathematical consistency and
then he found this strange thing he
found the electric and magnetic waves to
move the fields move with the speed
course of speed of light that they
thought that way and said no wait maybe
light is electromagnetic waves moving
just because of math ok that's what I
would call an application for modder
bates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you